sans un bruit le cercueil de la reine
qui de balmoral
recouvert d'un drapeau jaune orné d'un
lion rouge symbole de la monarchie en
écosse et d'une simple couronne de
fleurs blanches il sillonne depuis les
routes écossaises en marquant
différentes étapes afin de permettre à
la population et aux représentants
locaux de se recueillir quand on voit
ces derniers jours la magnificence des
adieux à la reine d'angleterre comment
ne pas reconnaître la beauté des
traditions de la continuité de la
permanence du respect de son histoire
par tout un peuple bien il rejoint le
palais de buckingham pour plusieurs
obligations il prend le temps vous voyez
la voiture qui rentre dans le portail
voilà ça y est les britanniques ont
aperçu une nouvelle fois leur nouveau
roi une femme d'exception d'une
souveraine respecter quelqu'un qui a
garanti le ciment de la nation des
concerts de klaxons des drapeaux
irlandais qu'on agite voilà comment a
été accueilli à derry en irlande du nord
l'annoncé du décès de la reine je crois
que la marque hello vie y compris en
france y compris bien au-delà de ses
frontières donc c'est un choc une
émotion qu'on ressent tous je crois
encore aujourd'hui et probablement pour
plusieurs jours encore en république
d'irlande cette fois ci à dublin des
supporters de football se moque escande
lead in the box un cercueil pour
elizabeth
emmanuel macron lui ne cesse d'impasse
de passer d'un mensonge à l'autre il est
la girouette de l'idéologie le progrès
consiste pour au retour du ticket de
rationnement à l'économie de la pénurie
au marché noir à la débrouille et au
cerveau nage des français c'est en fait
une épuisante et humiliante régression
pour le pays et pas seulement économique
la dame de fer sans dormir at elle plus
tôt tous les soirs éteindre ses 336
projecteurs à
23h45 au lieu d'une heure du matin c'est
une proposition de la maire de paris
pour faire des économies d'énergie le
véritable objet de lait de leur colère
ce n'est pas moi c'est vous s'il me
déteste c'est parce qu'il vous déteste
s'il me méprise c'est parce qu'il vous
méprise
nous allons avoir un nouveau président
je m'en réjouis voyez une pierre dans le
jardin de ceux qui disaient que je
m'accrocherai à la présidence du
rassemblement national pendant des
décennies non pas du tout je crois avoir
apporté une plus-value pendant les dix
années où j'étais à la tête de ce
mouvement d'autres maintenant doivent
apporter également leurs plus values je
suis pas du tout monarchiste
contrairement à ce que les uns ou les
autres on peut raconter mais je constate
d'abord ce que je constate c'est que la
république a gagné partout et c'est
normal toute l'europe est une république
et dans certains pays la république est
couronné et ça marche là par exemple
vous voyez je commence à avoir très
chaud avec cette veste
donc
[Applaudissements]
l'angleterre était le sommet de ce
système de cet exemple là et ça avec
elle ça fonctionne et d'une manière
remarquable la date des funérailles de
la reine a été officialisée hier elles
auront lieu le 19 septembre à l'abbaye
de westminster à londres une date qui
pose problème car elle correspond aussi
à l'ouverture de l'assemblée générale
des nations unies elle vous plait pas la
cravate peut-être
non la cravate savane obtient passion
vous avez
la france est à droite d'ailleurs les
enquêtes d'opinion tendent à le
démontrer assez clairement de quoi les
français sont-ils en attente ils sont en
attente de retrouver une sorte de fierté
nationale
la droite
a préféré voter blanc s'abstenir et
laisser passer un facho plutôt qu'à
membres de la nuit beck est désunie
ils ont renoué avec le pire de leur
histoire qu'ils disaient plutôt hitler
que le front populaire
maintenant c'est plutôt le pen que
mélenchon